[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
lori valo and chad davil's defense
argues over evidence in the death and
disappearance of two children
why the so-called doomsday couple is
calling out their own prosecutor
if we want to talk about inappropriate
that's inappropriate
the naacp sues the former president and
rudy giuliani
over the january 6 capital riot and
election claims
we have responded consistently to former
president donald trump's efforts
to disenfranchise african-american
voters
plus the newest hit show i survived the
crime is out and we've got your first
look
and the trial of a wisconsin man accused
of murdering his wife continues
as prosecutors try to break down his
claim that she up and vanished
you can't hide your body once you're
dead law and crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
attorneys for the so-called doomsday
cult couple were back in court
claiming evidence is being withheld from
them it was a heated virtual hearing but
the defense
ended up scoring a partial victory lori
vallo and her husband
chad dabell are charged with concealing
and destroying
evidence while valo's children were
reported missing
authorities discovered the bodies of j.j
and tyler ryan
buried in shallow graves on day bell's
property
valo's defense attorney submitted these
photos from his meetings with her
in jail and claims he's unable to
communicate
privately with her under the current
covet restrictions
the judge denied his request for valo to
have a private cell phone
and for cameras in their meeting room to
be turned off
anytime i call my client she has two
options
one she can stand at the desk with the
deputy as i sighted
with about two feet handcuffed to a
phone call with a deputy standing right
next door
or approximately 15 or so feet away
she's on a recorded phone line through
tail mate
and obviously we've had issues with that
i think once you get one inmate a cell
phone
that's not a slippery slope you're
jumping off a cliff and everybody else
is going to want a cell phone
an electronic telecommunication device
is considered a major contraband item
under
idaho code 1825 10 and
allowing a particular inmate to have
their own personal cell phone is
something i'm
not prepared to order in this case or
any other case quite frankly
the judge did however grant the defense
his motion to compel the prosecutor to
tell them
which witnesses he's already spoken to
i'll notice ironically and right up
front that there's no denial by this
prosecution that he's had personal
conversations with these witnesses
and that these statements have been
given he just doesn't want to produce
them
one of the first witnesses if this went
to trial tomorrow would be mr wood
and i would know it's not just this list
of people he's produced he says all
persons
all persons i've ever conversed with
so converse with regarding this case
it's my turn to speak now mr mitchell
you talk to a lot of people obligations
by
his own writing
both of you we're making a recording
here we also have a court reporter who
has to transcribe this
mr means i'm going to admonish you do
not talk over the top of someone else
here to break down the latest episode of
the doomsday cult saga is retired swat
officer lisa lockwood
and terry austin terry give us a 30 000
foot view of what's going on and i think
i speak for
all of us but where are these motions
going to end and are we getting closer
to an actual trial
well you know brian we are seeing a lot
of pre-trial emotions
especially as far as mark means lori's
attorney is concerned
but here's the good news there is a
trial date set for august 30th on the
misdemeanor charges
against laurie in madison county and we
have a july
12th trial date set for the felony
charges in fremont county now remember
those charges are against both lori and
chad so we are going to see
a trial at some point july right now
in you know this case against both of
them so the real question that i have
though is
how will the tammy dabell autopsy
results
affect any charges against both lori and
chad all right lisa we've got a date but
when this trial eventually happens
i predict it's going to be heavy on
police testimony what would that
testimony be focused on in this case
it will be from the disappearance in
september all the way until the bodies
were
found the following june it was nine
months of hide and seek so the police
were involved at all levels
trying to find her trying to get her
back from hawaii after she
got married and trying to find the
children all the people that were
involved
as far as the interviews in locating the
children the compelling information the
police have
regarding her her telling tammy i'm
sorry
lori daybell telling her friend melanie
to lie
and say the whereabouts of her children
and she refused to do it so she perjured
herself
and all of that information that the
police have is going to come forward
absolutely yeah
thank you both and now for a check in on
some of today's top legal stories making
headlines
a one-year-old girl is safely back home
after being abducted
when her family's suv was stolen from
their driveway
an amber alert was issued for tinley
west tuesday afternoon
in florida the hillsborough county
sheriff says the suspect
abandoned the car at a church three
miles away with a child still inside
later that evening it's a senseless
crime because somebody didn't wish to
walk
so they decided to take advantage of
someone who was already helping their
their mother who was struggling with the
physical ailment carrying some things
into the house
like i said less than a minute at the
same time i'd be remiss
all it takes is less than a minute for
someone to steal your car
the miami-dade police department are
asking for help trying to catch a
suspect behind
the murder of a transgender woman alexis
bratton was found dead inside her
apartment on february 4.
according to the human rights campaign
she's believed to be at least
the sixth violent death of a transgender
person in 2021.
detectives say braxton suffered a
violent and vicious death
it's very important for us to close this
case as all cases are
this one in particular this one the
family has been left with no closure
they're they're suffering tremendously
because of the death and the manner
and which is our victim passed away was
murdered
during the course of the investigation
we were able to recover surveillance
cameras
from the surrounding area and an
individual who we believe may have
information or
know something about the case has been
captured on those videos
we're hoping that somebody out in the
community may be able to identify this
individual
and provide information to us
one of the ex-cops charged in the murder
of george floyd is calling for the
prosecutors to be sanctioned
over the apparent leak of a plea deal
with derek shovin
attorneys for tu tau are accusing the
state of sharing quote
highly prejudicial information with the
press the new york times published a
report
citing three anonymous law enforcement
officials who said shogun was prepared
to plead guilty to third degree murder
and served 10 years in prison
but that the deal was killed by former
attorney general bill barr
tao's attorneys are also requesting
charges against him be dismissed
chauvin is scheduled to go to trial
beginning march 8th
tao along with two other officers are
slated to go to trial
this summer still ahead on lawn crime
daily a sneak peek at the newest show
featuring the twists and turns of crime
on the a e networks but first the senate
voted to acquit trump of inciting an
insurrection
but one group is launching a new claim
in court the lawsuit next
[Music]
a congressman is suing former president
trump rudy giuliani and two far
far right groups for the riot at the
capitol law and crimes anjanet levy is
here with what the
suit claims yeah brian that suit was
actually filed in federal court it
claims the former president and rudy
giuliani conspired with those two
far-right groups and planned the attack
on the capitol last month
this coup attempt was a coordinated
months-long attempt to destroy
democracy naacp lawyer jeannette wallace
says the january sixth riot was not just
an attack on democracy
donald trump rudolph giuliani the proud
boys
and the oath keepers once again tried to
disenfranchise
african-american voters by not having
the election results certified
this 32-page lawsuit filed by
congressman benny thompson
claims the insurrection at the capitol
was a direct
intended and foreseeable result of the
defendant's unlawful conspiracy
the suit says the conspiracy violated
the ku klux klan act of 1871
passed at the time because the group was
using violence and
intimidation against congressmen from
the southern states after the civil war
i am privileged to partner with the
naacp
to have my day in court so that
the perpetrators of putting
members of congress at risk can be held
accountable
let's have trial by combat that was rudy
giuliani at the january 6 stop the steel
rally
he's been quoted as saying the remark
was a game of thrones reference
the lawsuit claims giuliani mobilized
and solicited the support of the proud
boys and the oath keepers meanwhile a
spokesperson for donald trump tells law
and crime
president trump has been acquitted in
the democrats latest impeachment witch
hunt
and the facts are irrefutable president
trump did not plan produce or
organize the january 6 rally on the
ellipse president trump did not incite
or conspire to incite any violence at
the capitol on january 6th
but the lawsuit related to the riot will
move forward
and i look forward to having my day in
court
and attorneys for thompson say this is
not an attempt to relitigate that
impeachment
trial that proceeding that happened and
resulted with the acquittal in the
senate
i reached out to rudy giuliani for a
comment on this lawsuit
so far he has not responded brian
thank you back for legal analysis is
retired swat officer lisa lockwood and
terry austin
terry the naacp's lawsuit as you saw
there from anginet is using the ku klux
klan act to come after what it appears
like
everyone and their mother in connection
to this insurrection
but how are they going to go after those
who weren't physically at the capitol
you know very easily it really has two
aspects one is to overturn
the election results they're alleging
that this is what this group was doing
but the second aspect of the claim is
the fact that this was a conspiracy
so they will be able to reach the others
who weren't physically there at the
capitol
through the conspiracy charge and i
think they might be successful it's a
great act to move for
now lisa you've obviously investigated
and arrested people in street gangs like
the bloods or the crips for criminal
activities
is the investigation into the proud boys
and oath keepers going to be similar or
different
it's going to be similar in the sense
that what they're looking for is an
informant somebody who is actually on
the inside
who's going to give the intel to the
police the fbi
to talk about how they were involved in
it so once they get somebody who has
committed a crime who has charges
against them just the same way they
would with a gang member
in hopes of getting them to flip on
other members to lessen the crime
against them
all right so they're probably looking
for a low-level member of that group to
flip and jeanette
other members of congress are expected
to join in the suit right
yeah that's right brian the naacp says
there are two other democratic members
of congress
who will join that lawsuit in the next
few days or coming weeks one is from
georgia another is from new jersey
interesting lawsuit we'll of course keep
eyes on it as it develops thank you all
still ahead on law and crime daily how
prosecutors in wisconsin are arguing a
murder trial with no body
plus the harrowing ordeal of one family
when their car was attacked
by an angry mob the new series i
survived the crime
is out on the a e networks and we've got
an exclusive preview for you
[Music]
next
welcome back too often victims of cases
are overlooked
well gio benitez is here to tell us
about his new show
on the a e networks taking viewers into
the experience of the criminal justice
system
i survived a crime hey there brian yeah
i mean this is a fascinating show
because it's all about survivors and i
think that we're going to look at
strength and resilience and really these
are people who have gone through
traumatic things
now we're seeing how they survived it
how they got through it
i know jill you spoke to uh with the
family who survived a terrifying moment
when they were wrongfully accused of
stealing a car let's take a look at some
video footage then you can tell me more
about it
spokane washington lee allen and his two
children are
out on an errand i was going to run to
the store and grab a pair of work pants
max and lexie said they want the ride we
made a quick
stop out of it but as they leave the
store the allens are confronted by this
[Music]
woman
my name is lee allen this is my son
max this is my daughter lexi and we
survived a crime
my initial little thought when i saw her
was i'm not gonna even pay any tension
because i know this is our car
get your ass out my way of course
i am it started to get more serious when
my dad told me to start recording
[Music]
max call more people started coming to
the car
we couldn't go anywhere she started
yelling and it kind of
seemed like it woke up the rest of the
street people it almost was like an
invitation to come join in this man puts
a menacing hand in his pocket
i thought maybe he had a gun i don't
know if this guy has a gun but
i also don't want to make a move and one
of my kids get hurt
i'm a business owner i got a big family
i got a lot
to lose if i make a wrong decision in
life so
i always try to stay on the right side
of the law but a new bystander is on the
scene
i've sprayed and uh locked the door
spray you up
yeah that what you're doing
this i slam the door on him
and try to keep my kids safe and think
what's the next best move yeah so we're
going to talk to them you're going to
hear their story you're going to hear
their story after
you're gonna find out what happened when
he finally gets to talking to police
about it all
and you're gonna be blown away by this
particular story but how amazing is lexi
like you don't realize it but lexi is
the one holding the phone
recording this whole incident and at one
point she just stops and she's like
daddy daddy i'm scared i'm scared but
she keeps recording she records
everybody and that is how they were
ultimately
able to find some of these people is
because lexi recorded this
and then they posted it online and it
just went viral
and that's how they were able to
identify a lot of these people
definitely something you don't want to
miss i survive the crime airs wednesdays
at 10 pm eastern on a e when we come
back
the no body murder trial in wisconsin
how did a husband allegedly kill his
wife then hide the body
our analysis after the break
[Music]
prosecutors in wisconsin are trying to
prove that a husband murdered his wife
and made her body disappear
james prokopovic is on trial for first
degree intentional homicide
he's accused of killing his wife of 24
years victoria procopovich
in 2013. investigators say it was part
of his plan
to be with his new girlfriend the
victim's daughter marshall lorwicz says
her mother was diagnosed with mental
health issues and even attempted suicide
laurette says she helped search crews
look for her mother while the defendant
sat back
and drank a beer i was surprised
we were all nervous i i don't know why
he was drinking at seven o'clock in the
morning
well at one point we all had to go
outside because they were
going to search in the house he was at
that time
leaning against the back of the truck
saying i know that they think
that i did something to her did you have
the opportunity to hear anything else
jim may have said that was concerning to
you yeah
he was sitting in the kitchen at the
table and he's like
i don't know what we're gonna do with
all of her look at all this stuff
this place is too big for two people and
then he said
i know she didn't want an obituary we
didn't know where my mom
was so that was confusing the only thing
i knew
is in the pit of my stomach is i thought
something's not right
on cross the defense said that the
defendant has always maintained he
believes the victim died by suicide
the original but when we started
questioning
further that we you can't hide your body
once you're dead
then we couldn't find her what could
have possibly happened
then it became she ran off with another
man
your opinion of jim
[Music]
as time went on has changed from this is
a missing person's case to
jim is the responsible party correct yes
you're still pretty angry about the fact
that he moved on
to a new woman kathy friday correct i'm
not
angry that he moved on i'm
not happy he moved on so quickly
but how could the victim just seemingly
disappear for eight years
we asked forensic death investigator and
law and crime expert
joseph scott morgan exactly that
yeah literally there is no corpus
delecti
in this particular case and i gotta tell
you very enthusiastic about covering
this trial
with law and crime because you know what
we do have we have
sludge ponds this is something in the
narrative that the prosecution has put
up that he had
access to a sludge ponce in the context
of a waste treatment area
you have what's referred to as aerobic
and anaerobic activity and with
anaerobic activity
what happens is one of these sludge
ponds forms kind of a lid or a crust on
the top of it
and all the little nasties below the
bacteria they are longing for nutrients
in there it's a
an environment that is absent of oxygen
so they begin to break down and eat
anything that's in there
that's what solid waste treatment is all
about to get rid of the nasties
i've never seen a man so happy to talk
about sludge ponds but
here to talk more about sludge ponds and
the alleged murder of a wisconsin mother
is lisa lockwood and terry austin
lisa when you hear what joseph scott
morgan just talked about
what are your i guess spidey senses or
detective senses
start locking in on when trying to
figure out where exactly
is victoria pro capovich i do agree with
him because of 400 hours invested with
the search team trying to find her body
if somebody was going to kill themselves
her body would have been
found so she's not in my opinion she's
not throwing herself
into a sludge pond i don't think that's
the first idea somebody thinks of she
had used pills before and she also tried
to use a specific asphyxiation with her
vehicle
so you know short of her maybe throwing
herself in a volcano
which wasn't in the area but sludge
ponds were i think that
joseph scott morgan is right on i went
to uwgb for a year there's definitely
no the volcanoes in that area terry
you've
heard so far a lot of testimony here
what do you think is victoria's body
waiting to be found somewhere where she
committed suicide or did james make good
on his promise that we'll never find her
brian i've listened to all the testimony
and witness after witnesses for the
prosecution has said
that they looked everywhere they looked
on feet they looked on horses they had
canine dogs
i agree we are not going to find this
body it's been eight years
one thing i will say both he and the
victim
said you'll never find the body and so i
think whether it was murder or suicide
it's going to be very difficult to find
whatever happened
to victoria of course and that is the
major question this is a homicide where
there's literally
no body for forensic anthropologists or
someone to examine
lisa lockwood terry austin thank you for
coming in and
giving your legal analysis and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you